and I think it's so sad that the left
tries to act like a man giving you 500
to go to an abortion clinic is
empowering that's like similar to
prostitution basically saying I'm gonna
give you money so like go do this it's
like working for a mega multinational
corporation and giving all of your
energy and life towards them is
empowering but supporting your family
isn't
another big lie that the left has sold
women basically that you'll be happy if
you spend all your time in a cubicle you
know there was an article that came out
saying the most unhappy women are women
who are single in their 40s who don't
have any children and work all the time
and it's like big shock yeah because I
mean you're told in your 20s work all
the time work all the time and I totally
get that but at a certain point there
has to be more to life than that and
eventually women say oh I want kids I
want a family then they're like oh my
gosh I'm so old what do I do now and
that's why all of these alternate
fertility things are exploding